[Music]
hey i'm bryce charles and i voice the
boss in saints row
why am i standing out here in the desert
[Music]
it's because saints row is all new with
a brand new location in the american
southwest with all new characters to
discover join me and the volition team
as we take you on a tour of a whole new
world for the saints welcome to santo
alesso
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
saints row franchise has existed and
done so many amazing things where do you
go from there it's kind of hard to
figure out naturally we've looked at all
of things that we've done in the past
but the more we did that the more we
started to discover we're actually
blocking ourselves from the massive
creativity we have at the studio for her
to zoom out a little bit i mean the
goals for this product it's about making
the best saints row game we've ever done
weren't really expressing what this game
needed to be about we knew we wanted to
get a fresh sort of perspective coming
in and we tried to bring in a lot of new
faces into it and that's really helped
us with what we've done and that's when
the concept really dove in that we need
to reboot saints row
if this is a saints row game it's gotta
be open world right of course it is and
all the crazy sandbox action happens out
here in and around the weird wild desert
city of santo alesso the biggest and
best saints row playground yet
we're set in the southwest that is a big
deal for us because it's a whole new
bold setting the southwest has a majesty
the buttes the mesas the color you're
thinking of that red rock you're
thinking of that sandy ground the iconic
sunsets the postcard imagery rich in
culture rich in diversity and history
it's also got an incredible city motto
which is keep sento strange keep it
strange fits like a glove it was
practically tailor made for saints row
embrace your weirdness embrace your
identity and revel it
now we get the heart of our tour the
saints themselves who are these four
friends who come together take a chance
on each other and create a criminal
empire of their own
we've created a set of characters that
you're going to want to invite in your
living room every day
you have the boss the boss is brash the
best part is that the boss is you sort
of a charismatic murder machine nice you
did say we need to have our fingers and
more pies you know eli he wants to build
something special prefers hostile
takeovers to open hostilities as an
investor i don't like wasting money i
really like nina her way of thinking is
really family oriented an obsessive
gearhead and just the best getaway
driver in the business and badass
kevin who's come to santa aliso looking
for a place to belong kevin is shirtless
i don't know why kev wants to be a tv
chef you know what would make it smell
even better hey man if you want a 300
waffle maker you can buy with the
exposure the idols pay you in this reset
let us add part in a big way and that's
like the number one thing about this
game 100 they're relatable i would not
do what they do to pay down the student
loans but i get where they're coming
from all the time
so i made them watch while i broke their
dads
[ __ ]
but who would our bad guys be without
the even badder guys the criminal gangs
that rule their own territories in santo
alesso standing between you and control
of the city you're looking to own what's
their deal
[Music]
each of the enemy factions approach you
from different angles they look and play
distinctly from each other my name is on
the goddamn building marshall is an
international corporation they just
happen to have their headquarters here
in santo aliso they are strategic
assassins they've got high tech bleeding
edge technology
and they're designed to secure and lock
you down
in contrast pantera is all about muscle
and physical power they're part of the
soul of santo
they're tough and brutal and they favor
melee attacks and heavy weaponry to come
at you with full force
you're messing with the panteros you're
messing with strength
then there's the idols the idols are
something completely different they're
self-styled anarchists they see
themselves as icons in a new world order
their cult of personality and what they
lack in combat sophistication they make
up in numbers and so they try to swarm
the play
[Music]
[Music]
okay so let's talk about the talented
team of creatives at volition that
brought this reboot to life what are
some of the things they're most excited
for us to see play and experience
[Music]
we are trying to put as much attention
to detail as we possibly can we wanted
to create a whole new world filled with
discovery that each of our players can
feel included in
our character team and our character
customization our options are crazy
you're making your character the way you
want to you're building your criminal
empire the way you want to you're
earning money the way that you want to
all that together leads to the
philosophy of being self-made it is this
weird combination that i don't see in
any other games out there of humor of
over the top and a badass we're wanting
you to just be in the moment and have
that experience and the experience that
we're having is just bs and have fun
with it so that means next step is to
make connections with people that can
shoot guns come on man we want this
thing to be more than a street gang we
want to be an organization an
institution they're the kinds of choices
that i can make and the way that i can
play the game and most importantly
leveraging the experience of volition
creativity that we have with trying new
things out and then having this open
world where we can realize that i think
it's made for a really exciting game
with centro
we started this journey searching for
the new saints and where we got to is
it was time to tell a new story set in a
whole new city about a group of friends
hungry to create a new criminal empire
all of their own
but ultimately we discovered that the
game itself is about being your own boss
being true
being you
about being self-made
you